hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome oh oh
alright so hand boots setting mood not
enough mood set let me try let me try
it's a bit moody err not quite as
Moody's I would have wanted it to be but
it so this is faith now
don't be deceived by its appearance if
you want to talk about a pixelated
horror game apparently this is a horror
game all the reviews about this game say
that it's incredibly scary extremely
disturbing the reason I'm playing this
one is because there is a faith chapter
two that is apparently even better than
faith chapter one and I've never heard
of this game never way whoa what Oh what
to move was I will walk before the Lord
in the land of the living
all right I've got to hold up my
crucifix apparently interesting
oh well face demons and cast them out
with the space key or a button resist
the devil and he will flee from you
right okay all right this is going to be
a different experience than most horror
games because I think the entire game is
made in like NES style like 1980s level
gaming Atari graphics the kind of [ __ ]
that you would see in the minigames in
five nights at Freddy's like that's the
closest thing I could relate it to you
that you might understand this is
old-school gaming but as I discovered in
a game that I played recently even the
most basic looking games can be utterly
terrifying well well about demon all
right
you're invited that clown you're invited
come and celebrate Nate and Jason's
sixth birthday Saturday May 3rd 12 to
four directions turn right at 13 38
snake meadow Hill Road and go straight
past the well well well well I guess I'm
gonna go straight past the well then hey
how you doing excuse moi by out Deerman
you get it out Dearman out beam whatever
so excuse me what in the hell what was
that spider monster and what is this
house supposed to be assist the party is
this where the clown is god I don't like
that all right well it's locked okay so
there's no back door to this thing so I
guess I move on or I try to find a key
at least I don't know Oh
oh dear you're fine hey dear you just
eaten some grass out demon out Deerman
out Dearman oh yeah you better run oh
where are you going where you going
buddy how are you God are you just
trying to peacefully eat some grass I
don't think so you come back here that's
where that spider demon came from
[Music]
you know think about pixelated graphics
is it leaves a lot to the imagination so
why I see white strand II stuff on the
ground in such a pattern as that I think
spider cuz a spider web must've been
here and then it got disturbed I don't
think of anything else
oh hi okay
the Martins house lies about a hundred
yards off the snake meadow Hill Road
there is almost no driveway trees just
out in the middle of gravel path that is
mostly covered in grass it was difficult
to find the house especially since it
was already dark when we arrived
father Allred seemed to know where he
was going he simply drove straight ahead
until we arrived at the house in the
headlights I saw an old shed off to the
right of the path father Aldred
explained that he would rather perform
the exorcism away from the house
but the Martins had insisted that Amy
remain inside he complained that having
the family present makes it difficult to
proceed with the elements of the rite
that may seem harsh to the layperson
okay I'm sorry
oh no you don't do that to me
[Music]
but wipeout demon out Damon
no no no I will not worship you
what the hell what the hell is that
thing I'm just wandering now but I'm
just like I'm a little perturbed more
than a little strange all right either
way I got the key so I guess I should go
to the house now just gotta be on my
tippy tippy toes case any demons come
charging at me from the darkness I'm on
my tippy tippy tippy toes why
[Music]
but I was on my tip tippy-toes I was on
my tippy tappy toes I definitely
exercised that demon I did that Oh more
spiderwebs okay also hey hey hey hey hey
Oh Aflac Ben Affleck okay whatever
you're not gonna give me this time I'm
on my tippy top e2p toes I'm sorry
[Music]
hate it I hate it mr. and mrs. Martin
greeted us at the front porch mr. Martin
led us downstairs to the basement
explaining that Amy was down there in
the restraints I felt for him there was
guilt and shame in his voice Amy was in
the very back of the attic in a chair
perfectly calm staring at us
wait I'm sorry you said he was she was
in the basement she was in the basement
but in the very back of the Attic
perfectly calm staring at us it's hard
to describe the look on her face it was
you okay
okay wait a minute what with that you
get out anything okay I yield it no no
that's not good okay all right cool good
this is great
McDonald's french fries you get out of
here okay great uh-huh it sure is quiet
all right
ah that's a comforting family portrait
very comforting you know buddy I
appreciate you taking the time to really
finish what you started but why did you
have to drag me along for it
ah of course a peloton in a perfectly
beautiful part of the house
okay sure is quiet Simon Says out
diamond a Honda okay Bob must be
stationed somewhere in the Middle East
because he sent over this weird-looking
doll for Amy's birthday Alaska Nisha
about it next time we have book club she
looks like she could be from over there
and you didn't seem excited to see the
doll I think she would rather have a
phone instead or maybe seeing a baby
doll makes her feel self-conscious about
working at the clinic okay I guess I was
the only one who thought to check in the
Attic when I got up there who is
freezing cold
I found Amy standing in the back looking
straight at me like I first met her
downstairs we spoke briefly
although we was frustrating to talk to
her or it I experienced a bit of
deception from the demon during our
conversation she uttered my mother's
first name and in other instances spoke
perfect Latin I called for help from the
others but nobody came so I raised my
crucifix and began the write again
interesting so how do I get to this
attic yeah Damon I don't feel safe in my
own home anymore I hear voices outside
around the house at night I don't let
the twins go out in the woods to play
because I'm afraid of what's out there
the house itself feels stressed
distorted slanted somehow it's like I'm
walking through a carnival funhouse
amis condition has only gotten worse I
can't stand to be around her and I don't
know why she just doesn't seem like
herself anymore I want to take her to
the doctor but I can't leave the boys
here I find that the phone stops working
throughout the day and now I can't seem
to find my car keys thank God Bob comes
over tomorrow all right so far so goo so
is that it did I exercise all the demons
it's real quiet is really quiet out
demon oh it's so quiet and I don't know
why it's quiet I don't like the cause
I've got goosebumps from the coin oh I
see that's a staircase bottom right I
gotta go to the basement
it's quiet down here too I don't like
the Clyde
demon even really uncomfy the dog Oh
okay dear Amy thanks for writing it
really brightened my day hearing from
you in your letter you asked what's the
weirdest thing I've seen as a missionary
the area we are working in has a lot of
folks who practice quitting baba it's
what you might call a pagan religion
it's kind of a mix of Catholic and
African religions one of the Saints they
worship is San lung where Tay or Saint
death yesterday we talked to a boy about
15 when we asked him if he had ever
prayed he said no but I had prayed thus
and Allah muerte he told us about a time
when he stayed over at his cousin's
house and according to him they prayed
to some figures of sanli muerte and the
pictures make things in the house move
around he got real quiet and scared
looking after that we told him that he
could pray to God and that God wouldn't
make him feel scared like that we
invited him to come to church but he
hasn't come yet I need to wrap this
letter up and get back to work
see you in four months Laden right San
la muerte right
I know demons when I see demons and I've
seen many demons right in front of night
right in front of me one of you is demon
to know it I know it I know it to be
true I'm aware of this one of yous demon
I'll find which one o amy's parents
could not endure witnessing the
proceedings of the right four lon
mrs. Martin was hysterical and the thing
that was inside Amy was feeding off of
the fear father already asked me to take
the Martins upstairs I was physically
worn out but managed to get them back up
the stairs into the kitchen Amy was
screaming mother mother the whole time
finally I got them to sit down with me
at the kitchen table after a few minutes
we couldn't hear much of anything down
in the basement so I went down to check
on things I found father all relying on
his back unconscious with his arms
spread out wide amy was non the chair
I'm sorry
Oh
oh no I'm very mortis gonna live through
this nightmare again okay your dangly
fingers yeah no kidding I don't know how
to beat her
good great so if I stay in one spot for
too long is it just like no oh you dare
don't you do it I know which direction I
let go I let I literally let go I
literally let go I don't know why I let
go but I did I don't know okay I don't
know if that's the correct thing or if
there's a way to detect like if it's
like a fake out Simon Says it's kind of
thing you know what actually I'm just
gonna run away I'm just gonna run I'm
gonna run away because being here
obviously is not good for my health so
I'm just gonna get out of here cuz you
know I should not be here here's where I
should nah I'm okay I'm good thank you
please leave me alone I don't
all right so I have to fight you is what
I'm gathering from it so I'm gonna fight
you you Damon yeah what's up what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up what's up or so pusher oh yeah
you don't want to play oh okay yeah you
don't want to play okay alright well
just ladi Dadi de la dee da dee doo dah
Oh No
look at you I have no idea how am I
supposed to know so there's got to be
trick to this ray
I'm running ah maybe that's it
get out here oh [ __ ] oh that's not good
oh well that's something I don't know
what that's about
I don't know if I'm helping or hindering
it I can see you too
oh I'm not a hundred percent sure what
I'm doing
get it I'm trying to get out I I am
trying I'm very much trying I'm I eat
the vegetables
okay well this might be my doom
[Applause]
well you can't ask me to get out and
then kill me I'm not your mommy that's
for sure and what about this okay you're
not you're not there oh I'm gonna go
your eyes yeah exactly wrong wrong wrong
wrong ah it doesn't matter I was even
facing the right direction so that's
just like death but what do I do
[Music]
ha I got outside oh I got out okay good
um what do I do about that what do I do
no no no no no no no no okay well I'm
outside so that's good I don't know what
to do about that but there was the note
that said something about how the Father
Aldred wanted to do this away from the
house I don't know what I'm supposed to
do what am I supposed to do how am I
supposed to do anything I don't know
what to do oh oh oh no no no no no no
Bob Ross public let let tour
Connecticut's historical connection to
witchcraft Satanism and the the Beast
system I thought you said the breast
system I will not suffer you will suffer
how deep to the woods go oh hi weird mr.
Martin it is taken longer than expected
registering the markers on your property
as a historical cemetery our office has
had difficulty identifying who was
buried here the inscription on the
gravestones are written in a language
that we cannot identify I've sent the
gravestone rubbings to some of my peers
at the University of Connecticut I will
reach out to you when I get a response
from them
all the best Daryl Henderson's state of
Connecticut Historical Society all right
cool good why is this tree dead today I
noticed Amy's favorite tree looks like
it's dying all the needles are falling
off it and the bark is peeling I guess
I'm more upset about it than Amy is
she's totally absorbed in her
volunteer work at the clinic I guess
it's good that she found something she's
passionate about but I've gotten ugly
looks from some of the women at book
club Kathy and her religious friends
won't even talk to me anymore I see oh
well that's not good I'm sorry what am i
back I'm back here okay so there's got
to be something that I can do to this
demon
there's got to be something to be done
about him yeah okay she is here so what
do I do about that a little bit curved
puzzled you know oh [ __ ] oh my oh
come on try something I have an idea I
do that but do this this this oh that's
what it is I just got to keep blasting
it with my crucifix until I find the
right way oh yeah this way that way this
way that way
oh okay I did it I did it good for me I
did it I did the thing yes I'm so smart
got that on the first try
most indubitably definitely the first
try okay I'm guessing this is the Attic
not the basement cuz some of these notes
are a little confusing SC uh yeah so the
obvious staircase and definitely not a
bookshelf uh-huh Oh
Karen Karen the church might contact you
in a few days to tell you their version
of what happened to me I want you to
hear it from me first a year ago I was
involved in the exorcism of Amy Martin
what they said in the papers about what
happened isn't true she my superior
father with when I confronted her she
managed to cut the power to the house
and her own parents with their own I
have to go back to that house
the nightmares I'm having a real she's
still there waiting for me I can still
help her if I don't come back know that
I love you and I'm sorry am i John why
is there a smile on the mannequin I
don't know oh it's disco time all right
cool good hi I know I don't know about
that
is it working Oh what is that what do I
know about that okay I just I guess I
just run away oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get
cornered here Oh God okay that's not
good oh that I hate it I hate it I hate
it hate it hate it oh boy
Oh what do I do okay unclear oh yeah
nice face oh I got a then I got a react
okay I see what I got a do I see
so am I is this you cut off your own
face is that what I'm so I'm gathering
from this oh why do I need to run out of
the way I might have to run out of the
way
[Music]
whoa miss me ah guy yeah okay I can do
this
Oh Oh got ya oh I wish I didn't get you
oh I wish I didn't get to Oh aye you're
drawing a star in the ground I should
have realized that's horrible that's oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay cool great Oh what do I do about
that
oh sure well too late what if I stand in
the center am i safe I think I'm safe of
I'm in the center yeah I am uh well no
not that safe not okay well I think I've
got this so long as I can predict a nice
path here whoo oh [ __ ]
Oh God
ah okay what we're gonna do what do you
do okay goodbye well job well done time
to go back to the Vatican tell them that
a horrible girl demon just had a face
that had a head explode out of it and
then she sailed through the window all
on her own
nothing to do with me I did my job I can
sleep soundly now I could kill her one
bullet you say a gun with one bullet
here we go hey where's your gun cuff ID
did I do it I don't think I did it right
did I that was probably not a smart move
find out the smartest move I've ever
made yeah pretty dumb probably pretty
dumb I did
oh why would she be down here jumped out
the window she probably outside right in
the backyard in the back maybe I caught
the back door now maybe I go in the
backyard the back door back yard for the
back door back yard
Becky or no okay all right back door
yard back yard into the back yard gotta
go outside to get to the back yard go
around the back
Hey look a gun again wait oops Oh stupid
of me
wait so maybe wait maybe I was onto
something but I just didn't know it
kill her is written in Reverse as in a
mere or oh [ __ ]
give me the [ __ ] oh goody goody gumdrops
give me that no thank you no thank you
what the hell is going on here okay okay
December 30th 1986 dear doctor McGlashan
it is been 30 days since the beginning
of my treatment here at the Yale
Psychiatric Institute doctor spinel who
has been so patient with me has helped
me understand my afflictions and has
helped me to find a way to move forward
and accept the truth with dr. spinel
help I have come to accept what really
happened in September at the Martin
family residence I accept that what
happened was not the result of any
supernatural phenomenon but rather the
desperate actions of a young girl driven
to violence by her dogmatic parents and
old church rituals that have thought to
drive out evil I'm happy to report that
since accepting the truth my nightmares
have ceased and I now enjoy a peace of
mind that I have not felt since the
incident given my progress since first
coming here I respectfully request my
release from Yale Psychiatric Institute
contingent upon follow-up appointment
with dr. spinel in the future wait so am
I am I crazy is that the answer here am
I crazy or did I just say that to the
psychologist to get out of there so I
could go on a non Vatican approved
exorcism to finish what I started I
believe that is what it was truth I
would not be dissuaded from what I know
is the truth oh yes indeed I didn't
bring my gun I always knew the truth
deep down my heart of souls yes I do
because I don't need to kill no killings
against my really yeah I don't know what
happening here I'm not fully
right
alright whatever you say a little
confusing but alright
you know I'm just gonna go to my car you
know I I'm just gonna go to my car I got
a follow-up appointment with my
psychiatrist so I'm gonna make sure that
I go visit go do that I can't be going
without my medication for too long or
else I'll go bonkers
anyway I'm healthy and happy hey you
know what let's get outta here let's
skedaddle
let's skedaddle okay well can't exercise
my own car so I guess I gotta go find
her and shoot her with a gun with one
bullet in it I I could shoot you about
hey bye I can shoot the deer get some
nice meat some tasty delicious meat oh
hi hello okay so you're just standing
there it's obvious there's a choice to
be made here I don't think that shooting
the mirror was like at all obvious that
is obviously a secret and that's
supposed to reveal something about my
own personality here but what it's
supposed to reveal I am NOT a hundred
percent sure I'm gonna go shoot the deer
because I feel like shooting her would
completely defeat the purpose of
everything that I've been doing this far
and I don't know why shooting the deer
is better but it's the only other option
that I can see as an option to have an
action so I'm gonna do it not because I
want to but because it seems like the
only thing that I could possibly do
Kabang well
sure did that and now it is very quiet
here okay good oh she's gone she's not
there
why isn't she there she's gone she's not
why is she no there is it because I did
bad or I did good I'm gonna go with I
did good
unless I did bad and if I did I probably
am delusional I'm delusional I can't go
in the house anymore
good great jobs done I'll go home now I
feel proud of what I have accomplished
here unless I've done completely wrong
thing go all the way to the end of the
game and then trip over the finish line
which I have done before I have I've
done that before in other games so here
I will see if that is what I'm doing
here Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
unidentified body discovered near
wrecked car the site of a deadly car
accident is discovered along the road
near Sterling this morning longer the
body of a person who has not yet been
identified at 6:00 a.m. arisen called
the report and actually the long sink
mat of Hill Road the driver of the
silver sedan had swerved off the road
and struck a tree a spokesman for the
police commented the body appeared to
been dragged several yards away from the
car deeper into the woods after having
been ejected from the front windshield
it was noted that the body had been
mangled beyond recognition investigators
suspect this was probably the work of
coyotes please also know the parts of
the cleaned white-tailed deer were found
in the
the car from a white-tailed deer 100
typically gets 75 pounds of meat however
it appears the victim of the accident
was only able to carry 25 pounds back to
the car oh [ __ ] you let me do the other
oh well now I have options all right Amy
she prayers Amy feels very very wrong
all right judgment days come for you Amy
Oh God smell you later this is things
that priests would say walking away from
just shooting someone in the back all
right you snooze you pretty cool let's
go go I'm on just I'll just go now it
makes me wonder if I could have just
left without shooting anybody because I
went around to the wrong side of the car
there we go uh-oh hey that's not good
wait hang on that's that's not what you
wanted that's not what you want to see
one I know what if Murr just murder
that's all I get a New York man is in
custody after he confessed to the
murdering of sterling girl had been
missing John Ward of Palmeiro was pulled
over a snake meadow Hill Road right
after a state trooper reported hearing
gun shot the officer thought it might be
poachers the officer said Ward was
acting nervous as suspicious after being
pulled over when questioned Ward
reportedly said I've killed her
according to the police report of the
officer for backup after Ward became
increasingly upset saying repeatedly
that there was a demon inside her where
it was take you to sterling police
headquarters for further questioning
Ward then confessed to authorities that
he shot and killed Amy Martin a 17 year
old girl who had been missing for the
nine days after escaping from a mental
institution after a brief search police
located Amy's body in the woods near the
now abandoned Martin home in addition to
receiving gunshot wound to the stomach
Amy showed injury suggesting that she
had been thrown out of the second-story
window of the house and the officer who
helped recover the body told reporters
that Amy's face has been mutilated in a
very brutal manner Ward was found
dressed as priests when he was pulled
over it is suspected that he
impersonated a priest to gain his
victims trust after Catholic authorities
in Rome confirmed that Warren was not
nor damn to Minister all right good
great you know what I'm I'm gonna see
what happens I'm willing about that the
mirror is not broken yet it probably
said before that so I'm gonna go ahead
and shoot the mirror oh yeah here we go
okay we're gonna break the mirror we're
gonna go do that thing and then we're
just gonna get out cuz that's what I
should have done it I didn't realize
that I had the option to do the net
before so I'll be right back
ah ha got ya okay now I'm just gonna get
out I'm not gonna take the gun I'm gonna
go to my car i'ma go home I don't even
know if it's gonna let me go but I feel
like I should be able to go right so let
me go if you love me why scuse me no I
needed to bring are you kidding me I
needed to bring the gun with me that I
did not know that I have to do it over
again okay you're dead so now all I got
to do is kill that thing with one shot I
only have one shot at it so I might as
well make it camp I can't mess this up
if I mess this up somehow I'm going to
be so mad at myself and everybody
watching here we go it's time throwing
down that's what you get Oh
get rekt
[Music]
therefore will he deliver me I shall
call upon him and he will answer be he
will be with me this couple he will
deliver me a dagger be I can't explain
who a campus at that house neither can i
I can only have this and I did 40 maybe
hey that's the name of the game oh [ __ ]
when faith in doers yes yes yes I got
the good ending maybe the mirror and
killed the weird white Walker yes
sterling PD is enlisting the help of
local animal experts from the University
of Connecticut after the remains of an
unidentified animal found near the
Sterling the remains of the animal which
seems residents are calling the
chupacabra were discovered on snake
Meadow Hill Road by a motorist yesterday
the animal had been apparently struck by
a vehicle in parts of its carcass were
scattered across the road police say
they initially investigated the gruesome
scene because of the motorists who
discovered the remains that told them
they appeared to be of the person after
arriving of the scene police concluded
the remains were part of some kind of
animal as a matter of Public Safety we
want to be sure about what exactly we're
dealing with here said the Sterling
police spokesman this is clearly not a
deer or a coyote if it's a mountain lion
or exotic pet that escaped from its
owners or an animal that with rabies we
need to know about it and all experts
attached to the investigation would not
speculate about what kind of animal had
been found although they commented that
the animal was hairless anemic and
fairly suffered from the rickets a
vitamin D deficiency of their ears and
animals and children who have not
received enough sunlight oh nope I did
it I did I did it alright so that is
faith that was very good and it just
goes to show you don't need to have
incredible graphics to create a
terrifying experience there were some
parts in there that were really really
scary and apparently the sequel is even
better so if you guys want to see that
let me know down in the comments below
let me know right down there if you want
me to play more of this because I'm very
interested in it and it was an
interesting story too so you don't know
what the truth is
like you don't know what the real answer
is but hey that's the weirdness of these
games sometimes but thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to see
more scary games there's plenty more in
the playlist called scary games that I
have linked in the description right
down there or you can check my channel
in the playlist section I try to
categorize everything in playlists do
you even know that
do you even are you even aware that
there's a playlist section on my channel
with everything
as well as I possibly can so check it
out so thank you everybody ghin and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]